Tony's in Chicago hi Tony how are you
hi Dave it's a pleasure to speak with
you how are you today
better than I deserve how can I help I
have a concern in regards to my parents
actually in onine they've lost their
house through the whole housing crisis
over the last eight years they're
bouncing between renting houses and
living with family and in the last few
years they bought a house I don't
believe that they can afford it I just
saw the mortgage statement and they are
late on their mortgage at least one
month maybe two months throughout the
last two years I'm not really sure what
to do about that they have no savings
for retirement no life insurance are
they inviting you into the conversation
no no I mean kind of suddenly playing
your podcast like I'm on the work to try
to give it a hint like hey you guys
should probably you know get your life
together so we're not stuck with no
burial costs and things like that
yeah mmm well it's hard to watch people
you love do stupid stuff and they didn't
lose their home in a way do the housing
crisis they lost their home in a way
because they were in a situation they
couldn't hold the house I didn't lose my
house in crisis you didn't lose your
housing crisis so they lost it because
of they made bad decisions and now
they've made another one is what it
sounds like
have they got a home they can't afford
where they not manage the money well
that means money well not together my
mom and dad probably bring home about
forty thousand total that's like 20,000
listen they were making when they lost
the house no 8 and what do you think
this house payment is yeah it's about
1100 hmm pretty steep for 40 grim yeah
he's got a 72 month car loan on his
current car which is probably a couple
hundred plus he's got a loan on the cars
in the garage that doesn't even run mmm
come sir try to fire that up the wazoo
so it sounds like you know what they
should do but the trick is getting them
to do it correct yeah okay all right
well the only way I know how to enter a
conversation like this is you can't use
your son I'm scolding my older parents
voice okay you get the powder but
syndrome
once somebody's powdered your butt they
don't care about your opinion about
money or sex and so your parents weren't
really asking and so it's just like
let's pretend they're not your parents
let's pretend you've got some older
friends at church that are the same age
and you were observing this behavior how
would you approach them very delicately
would you agree and instead of driving a
bulldozer for conversationally through
the front of their mouth that won't work
and so just your only option is
persuasion and the only way I the best
persuasion I've ever seen is stuff like
your doing and that's you know leave a
book on the coffee table drop a podcast
out there that kind of thing but the
other thing you can do is just start
telling them about the times that you
made mistakes and how bad you felt how
ashamed you felt how scared you felt and
then when I stopped doing that I'm got
started getting on a budget and I cut up
my credit cards and I sold this car and
I whatever your story is don't talk
about what they're doing that's dumb
talk about what you used to do that was
dumb and how bad it felt and how you
don't do it anymore and how great it
feels now and now you know now my wife
and I are getting along a lot better if
you're married and you know now we're on
a budget and our communications way up
and Wow and it's just talked about
because they can't really your story is
not condemning to them it's inspiring
but if you ever had a friend that lost
weight and they tell you about their
story it makes you want to go get more
fit right but if they come in wagging
their finger and go you shouldn't eat
that pizza then I'm like hey formerly
fat person get away from me I'm eating
my pizza you know and so you know don't
be don't be that guy right that's what
we're talking about here so I'm proud
I'm glad you lost weight I'm glad you
got control but don't come busting into
my life
busting my chops without permission you
have to get permission to enter people's
lives that puts this hour of the day
Ramsey show in the box